I'm very proud of the fact that I did
n't get off to a flying start and
that I'm not somehow the
typical young entrepreneur who then
thinks okay, cool, how much does the world cost
champagne spray and something else and
hire 200 employees and
somehow have a remus office in every city
but I always said from the beginning,
Rean, okay, always
remember where I came from,
hello Marcelus Marcel h, you
said it beautifully, what an introduction. I'm
also really excited that you
sensed something in the preliminary conversation.
It's going to be great, that's wonderful  It can start
I'm very I
say definitely but I
told the truth I mean you're
somehow from the raw area that was
really born in HAM near Dortmund that's where
I grew up then I
moved job so because my father
was transferred professionally  I
went to school in Bavaria, then went to high school there
and then emigrated to Mallorca on
August 23rd, 2006 on Wednesday afternoon at 12 p.m. but
you were still a child, I was 19
years old, okay at 19, okay at 19,
emigrated with your parents,
emigrated together, exactly my father
has now moved back - it did
n't work out so well and then
my father separated from my mother
after 30 years of marriage, so it's a long
story and now I live in
Mallorca with my mother, who has
now also been a broker in my
company for 6 years and  That's going
great, we're a small
little mini team, you have to say
almost a one man show plus multi plus
an assistant and yes rock the island
what did your father try to do
on the island that didn't work
lighting technology lighting technology
okay so as a craft business qui
Yes, you really have to say
Mallorca, I think many people
on the listeners probably know Mallorca as a
holiday island as a
holiday destination, but
if you want to emigrate to Mallorca and
want to gain a foothold in Mallorca,
then it's a
tough place, it's not that easy  A
lot of people underestimate it because they think,
man, I've been here many times on
vacation and I liked
the sunshine in the summer and it's really
extremely hard and it's not that
easy to give what you have, on the one hand it's
natural at the beginning  the
language, I didn't speak
Spanish perfectly either at the beginning, I could speak
a bit brokenly hollaolla kettal
and then that was it, but at the end of the day it
's an issue and of course the competition does
n't sleep either and many people
simply confuse this
holiday mood with this holiday energy
I think with the daily work
that you really motivate yourself
when, for example, I drive to work in the morning
I see everyone. I live right on the beach, for example,
that means when I leave in the morning
all the tourists are running on the
beach and building their plans on
their wide towels  and then
watching and seeing how everyone
gets high live and also in the evening, for example,
or in the afternoon, drinking apol spritz
at lunch, white wine
in the evening then the gentonic and so on,
that's also an important topic, I
drink e.g.  No alcohol at all,
but I also have to say that in the
last 16 years I've been on
Mallorca, I've seen a lot of people coming and going,
some of them really good people
who have underestimated the whole thing, but
also alcohol, so it's
often like you are  If you're
stuck there, you really have to be careful that
you don't become an alcoholic. We've
seen a lot of people who simply
misjudged it and did
n't really take it seriously. I have to
say very clearly where you moved to
on my roof a few times
I've moved, now I live
on the beach on the Pleide Palmer
actually on the Ballermann on 69 madr,
no one believes me, but
you live in the 70 qu apartment 69,
you're not exaggerating, so that's why exactly
69 madrm believes so my friends
always say my God why  Don't you live in
yours because I've bought houses in
the last few years, so quite a few
houses that I then rent out for holidays, so
I have nice properties in the best location in
za, for example it's Beverly Hills in
Mallorca and then my friends
also say why are you moving there?  Not in
all these houses, everyone else,
especially at the age of 36, would now
somehow make high life followers and attacks
and use a beautiful house here
themselves, but I see it from a
business perspective and the fact that I
'm almost only out and about and
then go to sleep in the evenings  When I get home,
70 madr is actually enough for me,
but let's just get in, you
're 19 and then I read as a fun
fact, you've never worked as a rider,
yes, that sounds a
bit funny, but I'm
actually passionate. It's the largest
horse galley in Europe. I was there
showreiter was discovered by the headhunter at the time
and was then
hired, so to speak, and then
presented the show all over Europe on the weekends, that was four different episodes
or appearances, so to speak, and that's how
I got GLB. I got around
€100 per weekend
not really not much, it was
really manageable and then
I trained horses at the same time, so I got
€10 per riding lesson back then
So I know it
quite well and that's actually how I
earned my money in the beginning, yes, and then at
the same time I did a remote studio.
I read International Business
and Marketing, but then I
stopped after I
earned my first big commission as a broker
because I  I thought to myself,
I was 19 or 20 years old
at the time, and I
made my first big deal. I sold a €480,000 apartment in
Palm, my old town, to a guy from Mallorca.
I still don't know
how I managed it
In any case, the first big
check was on the table and then I
thought to myself, I'm now going to buy my
first car, a Peugeot 107, a
very small shoebox. I was very
proud and then I thought to myself, okay,
now I'll be earning at the age of 19 20 21  So
much money that I do
n't actually have to study any further because in the
end no one asks you as a broker what did
you study and you
always wanted to become a broker.
I think I would never have
become a broker in Germany because that's the case now  Im
not the best job to be
honest but in Mallorca what do you do in
Mallorca you can have you been
to Mallorca yes so in Mallorca
you can either only work in the tourism industry
i.e. hotel restaurant
but of course that is very
limited in time because at the end of the  Day the season
only runs for 8 months or you
sell luxury yachts but
I have no idea about technology or you sell real
estate and I have always found architecture
and design and houses really
exciting, the idea of ​​returning to Germany
then no way, no,
that came about  I'm not questioning
myself, so I worked my ass off so
that I could somehow manage to
survive here and that's what I did and
then at the age of 19 I
started as a real estate agent and I'm still there today.
Yes, that's it  It's funny actually, that's going to be
in five because I'm not a
trained real estate agent to this day, that means I
don't have any training, I do
n't have a broker's license either. I
just put myself in the buyer's situation back then
and thought about
how I would like to be looked after
I would be a buyer now, but
how did you, as a young guy,
come across properties that you
were allowed to sell?
I'm running
through the most beautiful streets in Mallorca,
ring the bell on the houses, say hello,
I'm a Rus. I'd like to
ask if you want to sell the house, then they
laugh and then they either say no
or I've actually already
had a situation there  Years ago,
an Austrian, a
60-year-old, and I rang the doorbell and
said no, not at the moment,
but we'll definitely get in touch
if we want to sell because I think the
way they approach the
customer is good and that
I think it's great when they ring our bell, I keep
their lifesty magazine, so I always hand out
my lifest magazine and
contact details, flyers and so on,
acquisition letter and then he called Sees years
later, I got the house
for sale and then made
real money with it  Well deserved so it was worth it
means something like what kind of house was that
example that was a 2 million
EUR villa in Santa Ponsa in the southwest
of Mallorca and he then
remembered that I had rung his doorbell at the time
and thought it was really
funny  and really cool then called
and I got it exclusively in V
Sales which is also special what is what
can you do if you
sell a house for 2 million what's in it for
markision 5% plus VAT
sometimes 6% depending on the seller I'll leave it
briefly
Matte has the math but it's good how much 100,000 €
yes you can ring the bell again for that or
not okay and it probably has
n't been that difficult to sell in the last few years
because it somehow says real estate in
general a lot has happened, you have to
To be honest, it's of course the
competition doesn't sleep and is
really tough. We have over 1,500 realtors
in Mallorca, everyone sells
houses somehow and tries to do
this job in some way, so of course it's
not that easy, but if you
do everything differently  everyone else, that's been
my philosophy since day 1, so
my 5 a's and I really follow
through with it and do everything
differently than everyone else then you
also get to buyers and sellers
and through the media presence that of
course also helped and  That's why things are
going quite well, so I ca
n't complain, I'm making ends meet.
Before we discuss the current situation, so to speak, let's say
you started in 1920, now
you're 36, so there are
somehow long years in between
Was the rise so you then
got into the apartment more and more by cleaning through door handles or
immediately great will or was that what was
the sales development describe
a bit like the rise from
then to now so in the beginning of course
first of all you got an apartment because you  Yes, you did
n't know what you were putting
in your portfolio and you did
n't really have it, you did
n't really focus on it, but I have to be
honest and say that I
filtered out relatively quickly that I was only interested
in properties worth 2 million or more  EUR on
specialist of course you make
more money if you
sell something big for 10 million. For
example, yesterday I was very pleased again yesterday
we were able to conclude a deal
for 10.9 million euros then house in ser
pona to a German customer who
bought it  Well, that's of course something
cool, but then I immediately
said that I'd
pay another half a million for you. I've got exactly
a little bit more, yes, thank you very much
I then said, man, there are
so many real estate agents, you have to somehow
cover the niche and I then said
I'm only doing it now and that was in 2009
in the middle of the global economic crisis. I
only do luxury properties from 2 million
euros, so I'm completely crazy, actually at the
age of 23  I started my own business and
really focused on
luxury. I said I would
only include in the portfolio the things I
would move into myself, so I
really made a selection when
creating the portfolio, i.e. the
houses that I offer and included them in the portfolio
and this 5as, this
company philosophy, this red thread that
I laid out, so to speak,
and followed the whole thing,
that's just what I say, for
example, we had the office in the top location,
but I didn't have any
money for the top location  in
Mallorca for the office is
between €5 and €15,000.
I didn't even have it when I was 3. I spent the same amount of money at the time. I
had the money to
survive for 5 months.
I bought a used X3. I
poached the secretary from the competition
and then I rented my shop from my office,
which
cost 1 a month with additional costs, so it's
manageable. I thought about it, okay,
if I sell one house a year now,
I'll probably be able to sell a single house in 365 days
to the husband or
wife  then I have
already covered the costs and if I even manage
to sell the second house in the year
then I have already earned money and
that was the calculation of turning two houses in the
year and last year in
2022 I was able to sell 27 properties
With an average sales price of
5.2 million euros,
I think that has developed quite well. I have to
get out the computer for a moment, you know me
somehow, Matthe is
there immediately for the higher than as a
service uh second 27 times 5.2
i.e. 140 million  um uh
transaction volume and then
somehow the 5% um my God you are
also a calculator Millions yes yes
like a football star I would have said something
yes yes yes and the cost base has
probably not grown much now
yes that's really that's what
I have to do  I really say, I
always will and I always rub it in my
face a little bit that I
used to give riding lessons for [ __ ] 10 € for
a whole hour
when it was as cold as -10° back in Nuremberg e.g.
US tax. I also have mine pretty well  Taxes were
already paid back then, but
I was left with €6.80 left over for
a whole hour, which means it doesn't matter whether I
turn over 7 million a year or
somehow I still know how much I sell or market houses for a transaction volume of 140 million
I just know how hard it is to
end up with 100 € taxed on the table, that's
why you'll
never understand me now. I also buy
luxury clothes and I live really well,
I have a nice car and so on. Well,
really nice, you just said
70 yes, but they're nice, the 70 is
still good so and invest my
money in real estate, of course,
but that's why you never want to see me
go completely over the top because
I know how hard it really is
to earn money and  I also know how
shitty it can be when the
fridge is empty and the first few
years as a real estate agent but you were always
self-employed and never employed. I was an employee at the
beginning and
then as a 19-year-old that was
actually a really cool one  At the age of
19, although I
had no idea, I
sold 10 properties in the first year and then
I realized it was going great and that's
why I didn't
finish my studies and then actually
dropped out, okay, but that means you  At
some point you saw how
it works with the Spanish one. I
then somehow went
directly to the Spanish real estate agent in Palmer. I then
just saw how the whole thing worked
and then taught myself a
little bit and just did
n't speak Spanish or anything
Actually, when I look back, I think I was
wondering how many times I
managed to do that. When I sold the first
property to the Maorina,
he said to me at the notary, well, we
had a few language
barriers and a few problems
because I couldn't really
tell and explain but he says he
has now bought this apartment in the
old town of Palmer for 480, so almost
half a million because that's how I spoke
the language, whatever I
showed it to him and he K  was so
excited about this piece of furniture that he
said to himself if the boy who is
showing me this is so excited
then I'll buy it then it can't
be that bad and then I
really had to laugh because I thought it was so cool
that he did it himself  actually out of
emotion he said I'm going to buy it
now because it's actually quite good what
he's saying, I don't understand
everything but we'll buy the whole thing
here now okay and then I
bought my little car with the first commission  Yes,
I was very proud and then in the first few
years you
actually sold two or three properties a year
or was it
always 10 20 in the first year
I sold 10 properties straight away at the
age of 19  Things got off to a
really good start and that was
continuous every year, so
you started right in the
financial crisis so 89 the hot in the
years up to today always like that that's the
average like 10 20 real estate so at the
beginning of 2009 there was of course a global economic crisis
First of all, everyone, even my
parents, even my mother, said it would be
better to stay
permanently employed by the broker and even if you do
n't get a permanent job and everything
was just on a commission basis,
you still earn your money because you know
what you have and that's what I actually wanted
More so, I also wanted to be my
own boss and I also had completely
different ideas when it came to marketing,
so you can see how I've
set it up like that and
of course you can't do that as yourself but as an
employee, you can only
do it more independently and so on
I would say that I actually had my breakthrough back
then with rent-to-own
living. I filmed 107 episodes at VOX
and of course the
focus was on it. Okay, that's the Mallorca real estate
agent and that's why it
really started. How do they have you?  They
found me
once. I used to start at RTL with
Exclusive Weekend. On Saturday evenings it was on
with Nasan Eckes shortly before DSTS. So the
reach and audience are amazing
and they accompanied me
as the youngest real estate agent in Mallorca,
so to speak, but how did that happen?  TV that
came the TV came because I
have a friend who works
in the editorial department at NTV Delux and said man,
you're so crazy and crazy and
different and then she's starting her
own business now in the middle of the
global economic crisis on Mallorca, the German
favorite or  favorite holiday island,
we should actually suggest that
to the television station and then they presented it
just like on good by Germany
but then suddenly RTL came
around the corner and then they
shot it and filmed it and presented it and
showed it and then it actually really
started because  Then of course the audience
somehow also wanted to know how things are going, is
he now moving
back and completely falling on his
face or is he making progress and thank God he was making
progress? Yes, that means
you were already when was that the
first contact with D  on television,
I think I was on television for the first time in
2010, so EWI 13 years already okay,
that means your whole career has
also grown because you always
had a television presence in Germany,
yes, I also have a lot of people,
I now have my own television format
The mallorc broker is currently
streaming on RT plus with eight episodes.
I have so many people who are
currently writing to me when they
watch the series that they have basically been following me since day
1, so 13 years ago
they started following me on Facebook
and to see how I
have developed and I think it's
really nice that people are so
interested, so tell me
what formats that were the entry-level format,
so I haven't done Jungle Camp yet,
okay, but it
was explosive at the beginning  did you say explosively on
Saturday evening it was at the beginning that I
rent buy residential rent buy residential did
107 episodes then I did what I
did 35 episodes of adventure life on Kabel 1 always about the topic of
luxury real estate then I did what I
did 15 episodes of NTV Deluxe always  around the
topic of lifestyle customers and luxury customers
and so on then I have now
made my own series with eight episodes for
rtel plus the Mallorca broker then
I have created a rich and heartfelt very
emotional format where then
someone where I am basically undercover
A bit like a cover boss,
I immersed myself in various
charities and
then I helped people on the street
or participated in various
institutions and
then at the end I surprised them and
then donated something and that was just
it  I have to say it was an amazing experience,
very emotional and I've
already done various formats but
always focused on my business but you
weren't a producer yourself
but were always the
protagonist in
other people's production rooms, just right and
now with the last one in your own
format  I then have the
opportunity to have a say, to
act a little bit as a producer, so
that you decide exactly what is going to be
shown and what are you doing and what kind of
ideas are there and what kind of things are being
shown, yes and how crucial was
this  Television presence for your
success as if it was now say that it would
n't have been possible without that and do
you say that was really nice and
made a few extra transactions possible
or say you
say I don't know the half of it describe
the impact a little bit so yes and
No, I mean, I'll say my
favorite sentence about this is actually if you do
n't stand out, you'll be left out. That means
if you don't stand out, you'll be left out if, of course, you're not
noticed at 1500 Marler and your crazy competition and you
don't actually have the reach because people are watching
you  If you don't know me at all and don't even
come across you or
land on your website then
of course you can't implement anything and
sell nothing. However, I have to say
after 13 years of television presence it was
really important to me every time
that I didn't do something I had
yes, offers of what I should do as a Bachelor
and what I should do were
all rejected at the time because I said
I would do something if I did something on television
or with the media then only
focus on my business and my
business to answer the question
I can say very clearly that it has been
endless support because
when I
walk around the airport or through Palmer,
people now recognize me
and as a real
estate agent I have to
laugh myself because I'm actually just me
I'm just a real estate agent and the fact that
people took a photo now that I
was on the meadow, that somehow 20
people came running and wanted to
take pictures, I can't
believe it because that's
completely crazy to me, I wouldn't be an
actor  or no, no Justin
Bieber or no star or something because of that,
very funny but of
course it's pushed endlessly, so
that means you're saying it's actually
not possible without television, such a
career is possible, but I think
the reach and awareness would be
without media  Don't build it like that, no, and
if you look at how you
act today, you have around 100,
40,000 followers on Instagram and the principle is that you
get a new mmobil exclusive,
then you post yourself there and
basically offer it, then discover a lot of people
every day  your own wealth via
Instagram, so to speak, and buy objects
and that's really awesome and I'm
really proud of that now because wow,
I got so much headwind
at the beginning because I
've always followed these paths or tried other paths
and tried myself
to present myself differently and to get out
of this boring broker business
and this dusty broker
existence. I said, man, social
media is super exciting and interesting. I
was the youngest or one of the
youngest self-employed brokers back then when it
all started with Facebook and Instagram
and YouTube  and so on, for example, I do
complete house tours on YouTube,
some of which have a reach of 300,000
clicks and the funny thing is that we were me in
corona times, for example when everyone was locked in
and no one else did such tours
except for my cameraman
Kevin and me  Of course it
went completely through the roof because all the
rich people, regardless of whether they were rich or
not rich, sat at home and
thought about it. Now let's
just look at beautiful stalls on Morkera on
YouTube at Remos and that really
worked and then everyone  When
they were allowed to travel again, they came to me
and said we've already had the house
three times, oh my husband has
already watched it five times on YouTube,
they can actually
go through with it with my family, but
actually we're buying the house, we
already know every little thing  and every
single one from the video,
of course that was really such a boost and what
did the real estate agents used to complain about
me and I said to the
owners that they do
n't want to hire Remus as the seller of their 10 million euro villa
because he posts theirs  Villa on this
strange Instagram and I mean
honestly but rich customer with a
budget of 10 million who doesn't watch
Instagram who doesn't have any social
media is totally dubious and why did
I always have to assert myself and
shoot against it because my
fellow brokers talk about it  willing, really jealous
and stupid, so stupid is now a
nice way to put it and now when I
look around everyone makes their
reels and everyone makes their YouTube
stories and everyone does their stuff there and
in the end you copy everything and
start now
I just think it's funny to do any house tours
because they used to
talk against it, so that's why
everything has changed completely. You
generally still have any
advertising portals, so now in the Scout
or I don't have anything there anymore,
I don't have Google either  AdWords and so
on I really only have my
own social media because I
can say that the reach there is
now so great and so positive
and also so good from the followers that
every second and that's really
interesting every second buyer is currently
in  The segment comes via Instagram,
for example, the customer who
bought
the Villa Santa Ponsa yesterday for almost 11 million euros.
He then told me that he had
previously been on the road with other brokers using the common
names and then
found my social media and my Instagram
Found a channel then contacted me
and they have now concluded with me,
so I mean,
you didn't have this B exclusively, but they
had several agents in the marketing.
Unfortunately, that's the huge drama on
Mallorca and there isn't
the exclusivity that you get from
Germany  You know that as a seller you
commission a single agent
to sell the house, but rather the house
that I just completed yesterday, for example,
is actually on offer with I would
say 20 different real estate
agents, okay but that's
actually quite good for you. That's how you get there
more supply, so more offer and you
're the only one with all the big
reach, so it's better than if
other brokers
take it away exclusively and then you
can't post it at all. Of course it would be nicer
if the owners checked it out for me
I'm the best
sales person and would give that directly anyway, of course
you're not
wrong, what you say is correct, of
course you have a large range and
if you of course then I want to
have this great reach then the
customers will of course come to me quicker
It's working quite well, so I'm
really happy that it's going that way. How
many of your buyers are
German?
99.9 yes, 90%
German-speaking, definitely
99% German-speaking, you can
say and the sellers too or the SP
mostly Spanish Sellers are almost hardly
Spanish because to be honest in that
price segment that sounds a
bit sad but in that
price segment there are hardly any Spaniards who are
then buying up properties  Mallorca
owns but most of them are
actually German Austria
Switzerland that means actually it's a
German business in Spain so to speak
you deal with it between
between German parties yes it's the
same at the end of the day in Mallorca
most of the buyers are German speaking
then come  English then come
Scandinavians there are now
a lot of them now I'm trying to build up the
Russian market but also the English or
English-pren American market
by
doing the event in America
this year in Beverly Hills Bever Hills
Hotel during Oscar week  I was
thinking about let's do Remus Teatime,
so again it's a completely
crazy idea, so I'm completely
crazy as a real estate agent in
Mallorca and I'm thinking about renting
the bar at the Beverly Hills
Hotel, which isn't so easy
to get to during Oscar week
actually the whole world is
doing some kind of events and
I pulled it off and it was a huge
success, there were 70 guests, there were
even extra customers who
flew in from Mallorca to Los Angeles so it was
really cool and a few Hollywood
guests invited a few really good contacts
and that was it  really a success
and I also saw LZ Hurley there, there
were a lot of them so there were
really great names and Hollywood
icons you really have to say and how do
you get it how did you book or no
l hley for example I know a lot so
I got to know LZ hley  about a really
good buddy who is
LZ Hurley's best friend and I met her
at the K Film Festival 9 or
10 years ago and I always
said man at some point Elizabeth
please come to my Lifestyle night Remus
Lifestyle night ma me  yes, once a year
that's my big party summer party to
just say thank you to my customers for
buying from me and not them
doing the MA in Palmer on morc in
Palmer just right you can come
write it down August 1st next
year write that  how many people
come there this year we had 603
guestsa so crazy and have a
dinner party vol Pulle followast
really with live act and and catering
and I'm also really keen on that
too thinking
about also London Beat I'm a big
fan of the 80s and 90s music  That's why
I always have
old stars from back then because I think
the music is really cool. That's exactly when they
played this year and that
was really cool. We had 603 customers and
BZ guests there, a big red carpet
and all the camer teams  and TV stations
and the press, I really make
a big fuss. You don't have to like it, you
can like it. I think it's cool. In the
end it brings me something. That's why I
have a lot of people who watch it a
bit and say, well, the one
with his  all the VIP stuff and so on
but in the end it's a
cool get together and it's
not boring either because most
brokerage events with cheese snacks and
grapes then you just think where is
the emergency exit where can I get out again
is boring that's why I have it
I've really said from the beginning that I
can repeat it, you don't have to
like it, but it works for me
and I think the most important thing for
me is that I
reflect on myself, so I don't live in
my strange VIP super voucher world on
Mallorca now, but instead  I check what's
happening and when I
go to bed in the evening and pull
my bed head and put a line
under it under my day then I say
okay, great, everything
worked again and if not then
I just have to analyze why  and whether it
was my mistake let's talk a little bit
about W hil because you
've just expanded into the USA you
did this during the Oscars then there this time and then there came
people you somehow know
from Hollywood so  That's hot, you've
already had a network somehow over
time in Mallorca and
you're also interested, so Mallorc is now
in the spotlight in the USA too, which
is really exciting and that was also the
reason I have to say why I
did it in the first place  Remus tit
Bever HS Hotel this year because there
are now
direct flights from New York to
Mallorca, so with United, that's
of course super cool that you get on in New York
and then
get off in Mallorca, so actually on this
little island  really cool
and that's also been extremely well received.
I think we had
around 50,000 Americans who
flew directly this year, so that's really
quite good and I had villarus in my house,
for example, is the first social media
house in the world to have the idea  I
also said back then that I had my own house, which I
bought back then, which was renovated
based on the opinions and comments on
my Instagram, which means my
followers decided that the house
would be painted gray, for example, which
kitchen design, Mediterranean garden design
and so on and the house can be
rented  weekly costs €16,000 per
week and I rented it out
to a hgef manager from New
York for 3 weeks, not bad, so I
mean he found his way to me
with his direct flight and he
also found it via social
somehow  everything about Instagram, yes, of course,
that means
you, the only thing missing is that I'm just working with
only fans as a
pioneer, no, it's really working for
me, I have to say thank God
to all that social media is going great for me,
which means Americans
are also becoming more and more popular  Your followers
are really Americans and I also had
some really good customers from America
that I visited with, which is
of course also crazy, they of course have
a completely different value or a completely
different budget then I also had a
customer from New York, for example
Then he looked at the house for 15 million euros
and he said the price 15
million euros said what somehow bevel
Hills or in Miami or in Hamptons
or what are you going to pay 50 million for the house
easily s okay then buy
two was just really cool  Because it was a
funny situation he had to
laugh himself as S I'm okay today
happy or according to the motto so no
problem but he found it quite funny
that the price development and the
approach I also find really
exciting as a broker to see that the
Germans are buying them
holiday property in Mallorca because they
reward themselves. They buy themselves,
so to speak, after
hard work after all these years or
after you have sold your company
how much can I make with that
house I say okay rental and rental and
this and that and what you
can earn money from is this and that and that
says okay then I use the house four
weeks a year I come all
August the rest can  I say rent it out,
okay, perfect, kill two birds with one
stone. We
also do renting. That's a great
story here. It's good for me. That
's so wonderful. That's it. I think the
Americans are really cool. I'm there and
I have to go back there  I would
also say that I'm really motivated, so I'm even more
motivated than the
Germans because the Americans think my style is
cool. They say okay because I
have a social media cooperation
with Bentley, for example. Okay, that's of course
completely over the
top
Of course, I'm also thinking about
which customers I
can go to with my bent, but of course I
came to the American with a Bentley, the
picture was RTL-ready again.
I have to stand there with the Bentley in front of this
house, of course exactly to
pick up the customer and also  then drive through the
area pick up from the hotel or yes
exactly I pick up either at the airport
or at the hotel or depending on where they are
staying I then pick
up the customer by car which is
again 5 because no Markl on
Mallorc drives with Bentle  through
world history I'm completely over it
actually and I know that too but he
just thought it was really cool said okay
how much is that car say somehow
the car costs 290 000 okay wow amazing
the newest Bentley said okay yes the
newest Bentley is totally awesome so  then
you realize that all these Americans
are completely different, he then
said okay that's good for you I love
it that's amazing great so PR also
said so proud somehow that I that
the customer is proud of me that was
still missing but then you realize  you just
the Americans just pat yourself
on the back because they say hot
guy, you're successful and I'm happy
for you and the German will just
say what does the [ __ ]
Markler have to do now with a Bentley so he's trying to
kid me, you know that's how it is
This German night company
has to drive past there in the Fiat Panda,
that's okay, please buy
it out for 15 million euros.
I won't have anything to eat next week. That's
why that showed me again. That's why
I'm bringing the Americans
to Mallorca now and that's why  also the
event and there is also you have to
watch a series of the mallorka
brokers now streaming on RTL
plus that's just the focus so
I said very clearly we
flew to Los Angeles, filmed there
and also produced there  and we
also really focus on
American customers, okay, and what other
measures are there
to develop in the American market?
I mean, I understand what
else there is, for example, I have
various connections, especially in
America, with some VIPs that I can
I just said we're doing a
kind of very open, normal
cooperation with the star, for example, I
'm very well connected with Elten
John, so now imagine that Elten John
brings me a few customers and then
I also said it very clearly, David  FR
is the man I spoke to
if you refer me customers and so
on then we are happy to pay
a commission so but I need a
commission no but that's yes but then
you do it differently then you say okay
Elten John has one  The foundation does an
Elten John AIDS Foundation charity
event once a year and
I said okay, then you just do it
so that if you now, for
example, refer me to an American customer
who buys a house for 10 million euros, the
commission is quite
generous, so you can  A large part
or a part of this commission then
also goes to a good cause STI like John
I met John
at an event and has
also been supporting the charity for
years and I have to honestly
say that I think it's great because he
For example,
Liz Hurley also
sent me both interviews for my own livest magazine, which I was
then able to print for free. LZ Hurley
sent me her photos from the latest bathing moon collection,
so I had the half-naked l hy on
my first camera, that was it
That's pretty good too, but at
the janectnet event, that was
also an event in Los
Angeles, so that's what I did right from the start.
I'm in Germany, for example
For example, when I was an echo loan, the brokers in
Malorka also tore up
all of my work colleagues back when
I was still a broker in the company,
so as an employee broker they
then said why did he
fly to Berlin on Thursday evening for the
Echo award ceremony?  Isn't he supposed to
be a real estate agent in Mallorca? What does
he want? So I
came back and I talked to Hal
and talked to everyone and
something else and I didn't just talk about it
and then I actually
met a producer for him
Music producer who owns a property in
Andr in Port Andr in the southwest of
Mallorca and he said you can
imagine selling the house
because he has so much to do and
actually wants to emigrate to America
because of music production
and so on and he told me  then I
actually put the house up for sale and then
I just came back and said,
I got a new listing, so I got a new
property, got to know the Echo Awards
exclusively and we're selling it
now, so that always
worked for me, but I'm still as I am  When I
started my own business, I had
nothing in the fridge, so I
really didn't earn much money at the beginning
except for the riding lessons I
gave there, so I thought about it.
Every evening there was some kind of event in Palmer.
Sunglasses, store
opening, gallery, art exhibition,
something  There
was a catering event at one point, so I always
went in in the evening because my
fridge was empty. I ate my
way through it and
gave everyone my business card, whether they
wanted it or not
some Josse Miguel Antonio or
someone else who sells his house his finkers
here is mine the card
calls me like that and I just have that
really pushy so not so
pushy that you
've kind of annoyed people but always with
the tactile feeling that it's  It was still pleasant for the
people, I
said here I'm new
to Mallorca, I'm the agent here and
if you need anything we'll let you know
what S the best corners in Mallorca the
best corners are actually southwest
of Mallorca from e.g. north of
from Palmer is the Bever Hills of
Mallorca with great large plots of land
very noble houses then you have
Benny Santa Ponsa Port Andras
works extremely well or if you
say you want a finker then
I would recommend Santa Maria or Allaro
is actually quite nice yes okay it
There's also an area like that, so the
Hamburg hill, I used to have the Bururg
hill, there's also a hill there, so if you
want to buy something, yes, that's in the
direction of Santan, that's
actually a hill where a
lot of Germans are really great  There are
houses up there, very nice area.
I think it's a bit too far
away from Palma because you actually
drive almost an hour, but if you
want to buy something, let me know and I
'll give you a good price. What do you have? How many
imobiles do you currently have?  Offer
300 so you can choose a lot
300 so you don't have them all
exclusively but a 300 on the website yes
and do you notice that the market
has changed a lot in the last month let
a well I'm also a broker who is very
transparent and very  I deal with it openly,
I also do my
Remus Sunday Talk every Sunday on my social
media channels where I go live and
then interact with my followers for three quarters of an hour,
so to speak, and
answer questions and I'm also
very open about that and I clearly do
n't say this  typical real estate agent nonsense
where you say, well, the market is booming and
we don't even know what we
can do first, but a very honest
answer: the market has clearly changed in the
last six to
months, I say
there are fewer buyers, but God be
Thanks to all the buyers are there who
can afford this 10 million or 15 million luxury villa or Euro villa. For example,
the most expensive house I was
able to sell this year was 20 million
euros in kamptar to a buyer K
kamptemar is between Palmer and
andratsch, so in the very west then
exactly west, yes, and the
buyer, according to Forbes or Wikipedia, has
a family fortune of 26 billion
and as a German, he is Austrian and
when he drove with me in the car,
he gave it to me too  alsous I
tell him honestly we have to look
as a family at how we invest our money
I also said a funny saying again
okay I have a lot 300
houses I'm sure we'll
find a lot
but I'm also very open
with mine  Customers how does the
family dynasty come to you too,
he came through a recommendation, he actually
came through a
recommendation, there aren't that many people in
Germany, and he's 80
years old, I don't think he has an
Instagram account, I don't know, I don't
think so  but dangers you have
drawn something and D mean he yes we have
some things exactly we have looked at some things
all cash probably no yes so
I would say my customers
all have the assets
to pay for the bathroom but still finance
tax savings based on tax options
Nevertheless, then most people
are smarter about a Spanish bank,
you have to be honest and say why, because
the interest rates, even if they
have increased,
you can still invest in your own money better
than if
you now finance the
property  As a
non-resident in Mallorca, you get around 50% from the
Spanish bank, which is
actually still financed at a reasonable
interest rate and you can then invest your
money, whatever you have in cash in the account,
in equity funds
or something else and then get more
returns out of it  because the most expensive
house you ever sold was 21 million
so it was now no, that was
last year 21 million was last
year again 2200 you have to
imagine 2200 square meters of
living space Munich hgef manager with
family then somehow completely new building
unbelievable view so amazing location
blatant quality from  House, yes, that's
really exciting, I think it's
good, it's great, I'm fine with my job
I'm just really looking at what
I'm offering and whether
I like it myself and whether I
would actually move in there myself so well in the 21
million EUR ha I would
move in myself but h exactly but still
I have to say that's some
quality  As far as things go, Mallorca has
changed and developed extremely in the last 10 years and
the whole thing has gone positively in the right direction with 1000
2000 3000 objects that you
can sell. In any case,
some of them will come back and you already have something, for
example the house  I was
able to sell yesterday, I've
sold it for the second time now, okay, that's him
one more often, I have the record
that I sold a house four times,
why turn around quickly because
often it's not because
people are leaving Mallorca again, but
as an example the customers  buy a
finker when you have had the finker for 5 years and
think about whether you now want to
have a sea view or a sea view or from a penthouse to a
house or from a house because you
may have gotten older. Do
you then want a penthouse or
So very few people have an apartment,
funny enough,
very few customers or buyers leave
Mallorc Qumer So most of them change
simply because either the
family circumstances have changed or there
is a separation or the family
has become smaller or has
expanded or whatever, yes  But
very few people live on Mallorc,
most of them are after
essential holiday properties, no, I
would almost say 80% are
holiday properties, even the 21 million
is more of a holiday property,
although actually in
Corona times and now especially in the
aftermath of Post Corona  I mean, there
are already quite a few families
who then say, man, on the one hand,
I don't like the weather in Germany,
I don't like the politics, so
everything has become a bit more
difficult now, we don't want to
emigrate to Mallorca. I've done that
several times  Because there are super
good international schools, especially in the
west of the island, it is actually
a very good solution for many people
who still work in Germany
Austria Switzerland and commute back and
forth but then the entire
family lives on Mallorca. Tell me
if you  say your new series is on
RTL plus, that's nurag payw
what you have to pay to be able to watch it,
you're thinking about something like that, so
your social media reach is big,
so I just said 130,000 but
it's not unbelievable now
So you could think about the reach further,
so let's say you
could also have a million followers
and you could
probably now run on the
larger channel where there is no paywall
in front of it, so you think a lot about
how do we do that? Tell me  I
know you well, I have to
say I'm not that smart when it comes to
the whole thing, I can sell and
I know my properties
inside out but I'm happy that I
can use my Instagram so
if you have a good idea how
we're doing it even more now Ken,
more followers are coming again then
we don't say anything exactly, so of course you're
thinking about it. On the other
hand, I have to say it was also on VOX at the beginning,
we'll also get a
second senddeep or an appointment
where the a follow
will be broadcast again next year on
linear television on VOX then in the
program but I think nowadays
the trend is really streaming
so but you have also consciously canceled a lot of
high-reach things
so you are already looking
at them a bit  Quality of the target group,
so you don't want a bachelor's degree because then
you'll just get a lot of people who, if
in doubt, don't care about it at all. I
can tell you now if
I had done a bachelor's degree,
I would definitely say 60-70% of these customers
Not then a
family like that with 26 billion in private assets
wouldn't come to me, so I
always have to be there. It's very difficult,
but I think I can do that,
thank God, great, I just
always have to carefully consider what
the limit is  Well, I'm in the
public eye and of course you have to
look at that too. There are customers who,
due to their incredible wealth or
privacy, discretion and also for
security reasons, don't want to
travel with a broker who is too
well known and
that's the case with me  Just the limit
that you say okay, that's all still
humane, but I have
n't seen this episode, but when you say something
like that is being sold for 20 million, you can
then see who is
buying it and then the buyer is also
there  on it and then you ask him beforehand, he
has to write under it and then
he says everything is clear, no problem, I'm buying
now for 20. The house will be shown on television.
Most people say I'm
not in the mood for it and I have to do that too.
I'm extremely proud of it because I am too
At that time I said to the production company and to the
broadcaster and to VOX and plus
if the W did that now and if we went
through with it I was really keen
on this own format but
nothing was scripted so 100% and I think it's
so cool that we did it  100
is really every buyer. For example, we have a
customer who we also show in the series
that she is buying three houses because
they bought the first house, then after she pays
attention, it's a
great story, they are buying the first
house from me  for almost 4 million euros
and after they bought it they thought about the fact
that they did
n't actually want to move in there because the wife
didn't like it, okay then
I got it back and
rented it out so I gave it to
Swiss customers  rented it out for a year
then I got the second house and
then they
bought it again I think for about 7 million then
they moved in then
the wife thought about it okay
actually the layout does
n't really fit because the
master bedroom is upstairs and the
Children's room the children are 8 and 12
the children's rooms are downstairs so
they are not on the same floor so
WD the house is also sold again
I also again wde then
continued filming again like that and then
you bought a house for 13 million
so that  is called and the W yes and
all that all yes they are German from
Cologne are very funny very and
those are z industrial family
somehow people exactly who do Hal
exactly themselves with real estate and so
on and those are z.  Customers who
then had themselves filmed because,
on the one hand, I want them to have their hearts in the
right place, but I also want them to be very
funny to see how they
communicate with each other
and how they are, what makes them
tick for you  priceless K totally totally
great we have really great
customers there and I'm really very happy
I can only repeat that
everyone said we'd do it
and then agreed that they would
show up and that they would then
be accompanied  And is that
a source of income for you compared to RTL?
I mean, you create
amazing content for RTL,
so that's yes, it has to
be rewarded. Yes, it was also worth it for
me that I did that. I have to
say it quite honestly  This season
now, of course, so that
means now it's for you
now if you say now somehow a few
million come from the from the
broker TV doesn't bring a
few million probably also
I can say quite clearly that I'm
honest  said about what I am as a
social media person, say as an
influencer, I don't want to scold myself now,
but as a social media and as a
speaker, I am also, I'll say
definitely 5 se s times a year I'm
booked by various companies
around the world  The topic of motivation and
personal branding, self-marketing and
so on, that I appear as a speaker
and the whole topic of
personal appearance I know, for example, I was
booked at Fashion Week as a guest. There
are different things that I
do and I think that's cool
It's not this stupid, boring real
estate agent existence that you just say, you're going to do
something about your houses
that you unlock and show and
try to sell. For me,
every day is different and I think that's cool,
cool, but that  That means it
's already television and it's also
profitable
to do your own production, so to speak, like
all the stars who have been
doing television for many years now, I
know a while ago with Robert Geist
or with Günter,
you'll hear about it at some point  I always have my own
production room because then you can
make it much more lucrative. I find it
very exciting. I think if I let myself go
a little bit, I would sound
stupid now when I retire
as a real estate agent, maybe in 40,
I said yes, I want to
retire as a real estate agent, let's see if I
can do it now I'm 36, maybe when I'm
40 I'll start my own
television production company or streaming
production manager or something like that. Why do
you want to be a mehkler at 4 because at
some point 10 years ago I
had the idea to do so  40 is done with
working, yes, I don't do it anyway, that
's nonsense, well, I've got it
in there. I dream about my houses at night.
I'll always be working, but I do
n't know. Somehow I told myself that
at 40 it would be good and yes  let's
see and you are you e still a
bachelor I'm looking so yes
that hot there is I'm looking exactly
h hello I'm on the application for you all
write to me on Instagram but
how can that be I mean that you have like
that  I've been working a lot at the moment, I have to
imagine that you're really
busy 7 days a week, you've got a
wife and family and so on, no
chance, no, and that's what a
lot of people don't understand. I'll
say that quite openly, I have from the
beginning  When I became
self-employed at the age of 23, I decided that
my business would come first
so that the woman
of my dreams didn't run away and I did
n't already have ten children, so as far as
I know I don't have any children. That
's just not the case  So it just didn't
happen, my God, but the good thing is and
I have to say, thank God
I see it that way. I'm still totally
relaxed and happy, so there are
people who somehow have 36 37 oh
[ __ ], I'm almost 40  still
no women still not
married and still no children
what went wrong so on the
contrary I say I'm super
relaxed and I'm happy of my
life that everything is going that way and
I reflect on it and I'm grateful
and normal  and down-to-earth and yes, clear
in the head and when all this happens then it
happens and you have a close relationship with
your mother, that's somehow,
yes, that's great too because we
really don't get on each other's backs and
we argue too  not even though we
work together every day and
everything is going wonderfully. Thank God for Hess,
but in the end
she is employed by you. She is employed and earns quite
good money, I have to say, because she
has made quite good deals, especially
this year and last year  had a
small, brief situation that was a bit
strange for me because she then
suddenly had a new boyfriend who was
younger, so how should I put it,
younger than me, he was also,
funnily enough, getting younger and younger
because it sounds a bit strange, I
have to  Briefly explain, I
once said to you in jest at some point, so you can
date if you want, but the main thing is that
he is older than me. I say
that as his mother's son, I'm 36.
Now please don't let her do it
Now
everyone can figure it
out for themselves. She then explained to me that she
has now fallen in love and she has
a new boyfriend, so I
'm happy, I'm really so
super happy that my mother is also happy
that she found a boyfriend
because it's not that easy in Mallorca,
so long story short
then at some point I asked, yes,
how old is he? The new friend
is like
38, okay, cool, then in my opinion I
told my friends, my buddies and so on and so
on  Then my buddy u from
Munich, Hal started
researching, so he was a bit
crazy too, but he looked on his
friend's website and so you
said Marcel, that can't
be true because we looked it up, he
then and then did his Abitur
and then studying, it all came
together over the years, so you could
work it out, he's not 38, yes, how old
is he, because I asked my mother,
how old is his
boyfriend now, he can't be 38, yes,
he's the same age as you  Okay, I'm 36, he
says so, and in the end
he just got younger and younger and now he's
actually and that's true. He
's 34 years old, so I'm younger, but
she's in love and that's the most
important thing, all the best  great great great
but you're also at the end h just
a small company tells
your mother you then have an
assistant and that's it and a dog
and then a producer so
video colleagues exactly so Kevin has been a host
for 7 years now
somehow we have now  On the weekend over the
meadows when we
were in Munich we celebrated
our 7th anniversary and we're not
permanently employed but Kevin has his
own company, an advertising production company, and
comes to Mallorca every four to six weeks
and then we produce
two days mostly four five
videos okay and all these Sunday
talks you do them yourself I do
everything completely myself Sunday Talk
Instagram Social Media everything myself okay
say a few words about franchises we
recently had
franchise entrepreneurs torsttin
Töller various others in the podcast
Martin Rütter recently told me about his franchise
concept and especially with you in the
brokerage sector when you think of Engel
Völker or others then it's
a huge question. Why don't you do something like that?
I thought about it for a moment at the
beginning when I was like that
became a bit better known and I
thought about it, man, it would actually be
really cool if you had several offices or
maybe even
an office for Marcel Remus in every big city,
but then I
quickly put that aside because I
think it can be done  Everyone can understand
when I say that the problem is
often God's fault, but it's the
manpower, the employees, so
finding employees who, like me,
are available to
my customers every day, regardless of whether it's a Sunday, whether it's a
public holiday, regardless of whether December 24th
is Christmas  always with the customer and that's how
it has to be in order to
be successful and then to find the right people
who see it the same way as you
and then not only think
about
Marcel Remus's logo outside and will
Next week millionaire that's
not that easy and that's why I
thought I'd rather leave it on a
small, fine scale - a one man
show plus Muti plus an assistant,
manageable mini-costs so we have a
small cost apparatus per year,
the most expensive thing I actually have
or expenses is actually the Remus
life status once a year otherwise
it's all pretty manageable and yes
I don't know if I'll
regret it at some point and say
man if I had somehow
gotten the right people on board it would have been
huge  Empire made but
I think you have to
say again Schuster Bib then perform and
just be realistic and down to earth and
be and yes say be grateful for
everything that I have achieved and I GLB
when you look at how El and Völkers is
this year too  I think it was
sold proportionately for a
lot of money for a lot of money what kind of
values ​​were created for it
and I think they somehow manage to do it
accordingly there then in each
office or local
I think that's great I'm totally there
I have there we I  Greatest respect,
especially what Christian Fölkers
has built. It's crazy, do you know him? Yes, or
even Sen Odia is the CEO of Eng Fkers.
I think I've known everyone for years, but
they probably like you.
What can I say about that?
I don't really think so because in the end
It's always, so to speak, especially in the
big deals, it's always between on
Mallorca, it's always either
Remus or Kers, that's why it's always like that,
but I basically do
n't have anything against it, so I think I
always wish everyone the
best and a lot  Success and
nothing, you have to say that if someone
is really successful then the greatest
respect because you know how
hard it is to get there, how important it
is for you know that for people like
Mallorca, that's already one of the
top three four for you  destinations Mallorca is
the office Port andrat is from narrow
people as far as I know it is the most successful
office in the world and I think they have
700 offices so they make the most
sales there oh wow okay Mallorca is already
a big market for them and an important
market so I can  To be honest,
I think it's great what he
built there. You also have to say
it was a different time, I think
if we now think about building 700 offices
in the digital world, I think it's
actually impossible,
even if I'm now  I'm
not very familiar with digital
and everything that goes with it and the
whole social media issue, but I
think that's almost impossible these days and
besides,
people tend to say that you do
n't have this permanent office anymore,
but that you're willing  and on
the road and you have a good
website, you have just
set everything up online so that you
no longer have this contact point as an office
with incredibly high running costs
every month and so on because for you
now in the 3000 Marler  there on
Mallorca who is the strongest
competitor for m i.e. England Völkers
or me, those are actually just the
two who are really the big players
so it sounds stupid now because I ca
n't compare myself with eng vökers
but in terms of sales, yes, that's why
It's either the two who are
doing the big deals, so there
are actually only
maybe I would say not even
a handful on Mallorca, so to be honest I would
only say two to three brokers
out of all these brokers who
actually have buyers for 20 million
So we have Euro houses that I also
sign up for the big fish, that's what I want to
make the big deals for. All those who are
otherwise running around
actually survive by renting them out
or because they are now selling an apartment
for 800,000 or for 500,000
or sometimes for 1  ,2 some house somewhere
in the complex or somewhere else but the
really blatant industrial and
really big knockers, I say that
is always divided between and
let's say if you've heard about Mallorca
a bit because the top location is the
high-end property that you want to buy
then you're like 20 million
up to and including the most expensive
house that I currently have on offer is
65 million oh wow yes but
is that just a window dressing price
or do you get sold yes it is it's
a difficult price  You can
often say honestly, but
it's a very spectacular house, that's
how it is, so it stands
out compared to many other
properties before it, okay, but
still, it's absolutely
empty and nothing comes after that for a
long time  come after that,
nothing happens for a long time and then there are about
as many as 30 35 20 25 something like that gets
the hang of it, but then you're already
very far ahead, probably so then
you're in Mallorca. Mallorca
isn't the south of France, it's
when you're in Mallorca  If you say you have a
house for 20 million, it's a blast,
so it's definitely an amazing house,
and from a global perspective, you said
everything in the USA is twice as expensive,
somehow there in the super, so America
is clearly Miami Los
Angeles be ville Hills  whole area
there and of course Hamptons then
of course there is a lot of competition especially
in Europe from the south of France to Mallorca
and that's about it so there
aren't really many of the B yes
syt is a different market so syt
and kitspü are of course also
fundamentally good  Markets are very exciting
markets, especially in the German-speaking area,
but obviously different from Mallorca,
but in the end they still have the same
customers, so I have a lot of
customers, for example, who have their
holiday property in Mallorca and on
Silt and then the ski hut in
Kitspül, that's actually how it is
actually a good market so
you should actually cover that but
you can't do everything but in the
end what a lot of people do that means
that's a pattern you recognize total
pattern total pattern I have quite I
have I would really say half of
my customers  They then have, so to speak,
the pandon to Mallorca, definitely
either as I said either on S or
on or in Kitsbül or everything that
's unbelievable yes definitely
okay and Steinberger See or
things like that but that's almost
boring tegern and  stnbergers is
also beautiful and also very elegant and great
but well, the price is different, it was also
expensive, also very expensive, but
at the end of the day that's really
what people say, man, we're
spending the summer in Mallorca, then
we're still there  in between on St and
then at the winter in the kids' office are okay
and when we worked it is
now so that you have a lot
to do with heirs as many of them are really exciting and
the main part of your customers are
no longer the
entrepreneurs themselves but rather  the heirs
actually and they say very
clearly when they come to me that they want to
be looked after by me because I
am 36 myself and not somehow
the typical 60-year-old Markler on
Mallorca and so I would
also say definitely  30 40% are
inheritance generation per year so
when I look at the customers and
the work but actually
you can't say that, no, you can't
say that, I have heirs that are very
exciting and they also form
a global empire from the brand  For
example, I recently had one
where my grandfather founded the company and
it was quite good throughout Germany and
so it worked well, but
then he pushed it so hard and
made it big that it became a global brand and a
global corporation  Very
interesting, of course, it's always
exciting to spend
three five hours or the
whole day with people like that because you talk
about this whole situation and I
often ask because
it makes me wonder how it is
I also recently asked a customer,
everyone in
the whole world knows their last name then
the one next to me in the car we
looked at the houses D said I am then can
I ask a question he says yes he
says I am her last name  What would
you say, is your last name a curse
or a blessing? That was a crass question. I asked him
something like that, he explained it to me
that it's often
a door opener when he says
what his name is, but it's also often a
crass opinion  Or put it like that, you
're just prejudiced when you
hear the name in advance, so you
say it can be anything, it can be, as you
say yourself, a blessing or a curse,
so I also find it really interesting
when you look at these
people's views  Listen to what they
say, it's pretty good, okay, okay, but tell me,
where did you
meet Christian Vöker? I
met him because I started my
career when I was 19 and
then sold 10 properties in the first year
When I was 19 years old, I actually worked
at Engel fökers ah ah okay in Palmer
right in the office
and there was a time in front of it and then when
I opened the office
in Palmer right at the harbor
that was when I was there, well my God there
I was  I was excited because I was
wearing the tsarist suit that was way too big and
the tie was way too tight,
you know, people used to have such big knots, that's
not the case anymore, and
then I was so excited that I
got to meet Christian Völkers
because that's what it is  Yes, of course, the icon is
actually among the brokers, you have to
say, or especially among the founders, and
then he came to the port for the shop opening in
Palmer, but that was the
only time. I met him again at the
Polo K, but I saw him again
That means he'll think to himself
by now, [ __ ], I somehow had this guy
on the team back then and now
he's giving me competition, that could
be something. I don't know what he's thinking
when he sees me, how do you even start wearing the suit,
so when I run
I don't have a suit anymore, no,
I'm now in a position where I say,
my God, I'm above it. I
sometimes come to the viewing in
training pants or a T-shirt
and I'm very, very relaxed about
something and that's also good  the customers
then okay the 80 yes I'm already there
my mother says my God can you
dress them properly I say
yes but I'll go to the gym afterwards
after the inspection then I can go
straight with the sports trousers and the Adidas
or n says  Then my mother rolls
her eyes and says, my God, you're showing your
house for 15 million euros, get dressed
properly, but I
think that's because she
's the mother, every mother
always says that, but the customers really think so
Customers are super easy, you
also have to say that my customers on
Mallorca often come
either from their boat or from the beach
or from the beach club or are
somehow out and about in loose, casual clothing
with flip flops and
shorts, so I find it then
Sometimes it's a bit exaggerated - there are real
estate agents who come to
Mallorca in August when it's 35°C, wearing a suit
with a fine tweed and a
tie then tied around them for the
viewing. I think that's a
bit too much, but everyone likes it  He
says I just don't do it any more,
I used to do it too, not
anymore and what are you buying yourself?
I mean, you're trading, but you
have your own property,
after which what what are you buying because I'm buying
now sounds like that again  funny purchase
either at Ballermann or in the
most expensive area son again on Mallorca
strange combination but I'm big
and if you know Mallorca I'm a big
fan of the pleide Palmer that's
Ballermann and if you've been there before you
know it has a really great one there  The
beach is super long,
super white, great water, clean everything and I
bought my first apartment there years ago, I think 10 years ago, and I
already said in the interview at good
by Germany that it will be here
so Pleide Palmer will be Miami Beach
and  We're so step by step, so little by little
PP it's going in the right
direction, less and less drunk, better and
better shops, so cool restaurants with
live DJs and cool design, delicious food,
healthy food and so on and I
renovated this apartment back then so a
bit about style  I've done everything, I know
everything, everything has been beautifully renovated and I'm renting them out
now. I think they're 66 square meters and the
figures are 1600 € per month. The
long-term rental is a really great
return and I now
have I don't know F four five apartments
On the
beach then I have a penthouse
in Palmer with an amazing view of the
cathedral and the harbor and four
houses now in ZA and a plot of
land aha that means you're buying
because you think that somehow the
Ballamann
area is being developed and so on just because
that's it  Premium is and premium
always remains premium. It's
like that, that's actually the case if you're going out.
Again, it's the best of the best
and the price will continue to
develop upwards, okay, and that's where you're at,
but also with financing
somehow  So the things are pure, yes, but always so
humane, so of course also for
tax reasons, I finance
one or two things,
but not now, so I always have
a bit of respect because of
course I also know a lot of colleagues or
brokers or investment people like that  It's
completely about
investing and also financing, especially
with the interest situation, the skin is
now all gone because they
have done 100% financing, that doesn't exist in
Spain at all, which means the
maximum that I have now financed
per house, for example, is also ever  after what kind
of house but the maximum is 50%.
and then, for example, renovation, I
bought a house for 3 million,
renovated it for a million, is now
worth about 7 million and
is now rented out for 250,000 € a year, for example,
so that means everything is
really great, so it is  a good
return, financed sensibly under
reasonable conditions and brings
good money and what is a long-term
goal, so now with the properties
you want to build a real portfolio,
yes the long-term goal is
to make a million euros in rental income per year with the properties, okay that
's it  yes, then probably not
so bad no, it's not that far
away, there's still a house missing and
I've already bought it and it's going to be
renovated next year and then we'll have
it finished and then I'll be 40 soon
and then
maybe that's it  Already retired at
38, no, nonsense, of course it's
all in good fun, but I think I'm just
really up for it and I
notice that even if you really say you
're making a conclusion, people notice,
on the one hand, as a real estate agent, it's very important that I do
n't have to  sell, that means I do
n't have this pressure to show this
typical magler nonsense
and say, dear customer, this is
the best house for you now and
you should buy it because
you'll never get this chance again and, incidentally,
I have it tomorrow  the next viewing
and I think the customer is going to buy,
so they should finally
decide today, you know, that's nonsense,
I just don't, so people notice
with me that I'm authentic, I'm genuine, I'm
serious about what I'm saying, I
'll have it afterwards  Even after the purchase or
sale, I still have a great relationship with all of my customers and
buyers and sell. I
often go with the food wars and the house is then put back on sale a few years
later. There are an
incredible number of recommendations now
and that's just that if you
really  If you are genuine and honest and
work authentically and sensibly, cleanly and properly, then you will be
successful, which means that in the end you will
also buy the objects
that you think will be sold
For example, my first villa was Villa Remus, which was
basically the first social media
house that was then renovated by my followers.
That's one of the
things in one of the houses, yes,
I once showed that when rent-buying
living, that was it  Long-
established Mayok family from
whom I bought it, who owned it
and I showed the house 8 years ago at
rent-to-own and then
they took it away from the market
and didn't
put it in the portfolio anymore. They didn't want to sell it anymore
and at some point they did  She
called me and a few other
brands also said, man, I'm
now 88, I want to sell it
and I thought the house was so
cool back then and somehow that had such a
special situation for me, such a strange
special situation that I was just
like  I was a small broker from rent-to-own, I
live in this house, I
filmed it and then I had the
financial opportunity to
buy it myself and then I
looked at it with my mother and
said here, look, it's an
old house but it's real  Potential
and then I bought it myself and that's what I
think or I
recently bought a house, for example, which
is also a situation like that, it's just super
emotional about this house.
I also rang the bell in Sonbeda 15 years ago as a
small real estate agent olla olla
Hello, you want to sell your house
English owner and they
said no we are not interested who sell
all blah and go I say okay no
problem never mind then I'll come back
next year that's how I
rang the doorbell again and again every year then
I got something  Once I brought a
poinsettia over for Christmas and
gave it a little present and
so on and now the mother has
died, unfortunately of cancer,
and the daughter remembered
that I exist as a real estate agent and she
is almost with me  grew up
because I started ringing there years ago
and kept
coming and then it was
such a blatant thing, super emotional, she
said Marcel, my mother had
died and she told me shortly before she
died, Marcel would call Remus  He should
buy our house D I did then
she told me that I did but she did
n't mean that I should buy it
but she said
that I should sell it as a real estate agent
she said no she WS you to buy the
house how  I'm coming because now I ca
n't buy his place for it 3 million now
I just have I've already
really shopped endlessly she says
do BU the house s I okay let me
think about it for a day I told
my mother that she says  want
me to buy the house, say as you
can, not the house now, she has
now died and she
told her daughter before she died that I should
buy it, I have to buy it now, then
I have a totally crazy story, it gives me
goosebumps  really
strange thing and then I
spoke to the daughter again, to
the father and so on, then we
agreed on the price and I said
okay then I'm coming so I'm doing it
now because I've
actually always had this house  It was such a
stark situation at the beginning of my
career. I stood in front of this house, mega
impressive, 3000 square meters of land, mega
fat villa with 1000 square meters of living space, huge pool,
fat pillars in front of it, very
classic villa and I always thought the house was
really great and now
I have the house  Bought three weeks ago
now it's being renovated and I'm moving
in there myself so I'm moving
out of my 69 square meter house
soon and then you'll move in
again then I'll move in again yeah what
's wrong with the neighboring islands IB
or  Formentera also
felt a bit around the corner so I do it
now and then when there are a lot of
football customers, all the footballers
actually all come to me and when now for example
German football Bundesliga
Bundesliga national players exactly when now
for example then customers or footballers
say they want one somehow
Rent a house on iber for three weeks
then I'll organize it but
still the focus is actually on
Mallorca, that means buying property in the IB
or messing up something, you do
n't do anything but for good contacts I do
the D so I wouldn't
open an office on IBZ now  I would
n't put three employees
there again, but if someone says,
man, I'm looking for a house for which I have 2
million or 5 million on Ibiz, then
I'll run, okay, and then
you'll find what that means. You first have the
buyer and then  Because they are
exclusive, you just
look at what's going on there and then you suggest a
few things and then you choose a
thing like that and I have to be
honest: because of the market on
Mallorca you know a lot of them
For example, I also have a property developer in
Mallorca from whom I sold two houses
this year, including one for 16.5
million, for example below, and he is
currently building a lot of houses on IB
and that means you know
the people through the network anyway  then
deliver the right quality but
also there's a total boom so IB Mallorca
I have to say I'm
on the road so much and travel so much and every time
I come back to Mallorca
I have to say man that's really
from Europe if you look at it  If you look at Europe,
for me Mallorca is the most beautiful
location to live in. Internationally, it's
busy all year round. You have a great
airport, the climate is perfect, you
have a lot to offer in terms of cuisine, you
can live there safely, it's also very important
for many of my customers that you're in
Compared to the south of France, where of course
many people had their houses in the beginning, they
sold their houses and their
properties in Can and Sonon Trope
and so on because there were too many
burglaries that they said they would
rather buy on Mork now, not a
good location because it is an island
and  The burglars ca
n't get off this island so quickly
because it's actually, let's say,
time-consuming for a German
to buy something so there is
taxation if you somehow
live there for so long then you have a
relocation tax and there is
I have all kinds of topics
with me, so I have the best
tax advisors and also lawyers
now after all these years
in my local network, so to speak. I have an
offer, which means that if the customer
says he wants to buy something, then I give
them these people  and
they then talk to the
tax advisors in Germany, Austria
or Switzerland and find the
best solution on how to buy the property, whether
you set up a company or a
Spanish SL GmbH or
buy it in your private name or because of the children
Inheritance tax, you have an
exemption amount of €700,000 per person and
if that goes over that then you have to
pay wealth tax, but that can
all be managed and handled sensibly through
financing through a Spanish bank  The
cost of everything I buy is
now not that much higher than if I were
in Hamburg or Berlin or just as easy,
that's really easy, yes and are Germans still welcome in this form in
Spain on Mallorca
or are you happy about it  Or
is it somehow that the Spaniards
think what's the point of all this crap here?
So first of all I have to say that
basically everything is good and that
everything is positive. Of course there are
a few voices here and there that
have been in the press, especially this year  I often read that
the Spaniards
complain a bit that the prices have
gone up so high that the typical
normal waiter, for example,
Antonio, who earns €1200 a
month, can no longer
pay for his living space
Apartment can no longer cover your rent,
that's of course a
bit of a problem, but
at the end of the day that's unfortunately the same in all
big cities, i.e. in Germany,
so in terms of salary it's getting
less and less or with the overall
inflation and everything  what's happening in the
world right now, all the wild things are
costing more and more wages ca
n't keep up and how are you supposed to
manage and finance it all?
7000 500
madrm and I have now submitted an application
that is at the town hall and
I want a tiny one, also a
crazy idea but I think it's
really good to make a tiny house park.
Remus the whole thing is called tiny house park
and it's supposed to be for the homeless because
I thought about it, it's actually
a really nice thing and you have to do it
sometimes. You can't just sell on your mobile for
20 million and have a kind of
luxurious lifestyle, but since I
have the property there anyway and don't have a
building permit, I
thought about that  It's actually a really
nice thing if you
build 20 tiny houses on top of it and then give
homeless people from Palmer the opportunity
to find or offer shelter or accommodation there,
so to speak, so that they
can move in there sensibly and
have a place to stay  so to speak and
now I'm curious what they're thinking about in the
town hall and in the inselrad
it's now at the town hall then go
to the con that's the inselrad and they
have to decide whether I
get a permit then it's actually
feasible because you go through
it  Tiny houses are movable and
you can build anything that is movable, the
only important thing is that you do
n't build a foundation, i.e. no
concrete slab. Yes, now
I'm excited about
that
Palmer and 15 minutes from the
airport so totally central Saranassa
is the name of the place that is at the PLE of
Palma about 10 minutes from the beach and
then I would be there in the middle of the
whole thing there are 7500 mad so huge I would be
a container like that you know these
container poles that you can set up like
this, it's like a shipping container and then
you can make a pool out of it like this
and then I would build such a
luxury dixylo like this like
a little house like this
I have my
own water fountain, which means
water wouldn't be a problem with a
generator or somehow with
photovoltaics or solar. What can
you get electricity? Do you have many craftsmen
who work for you? Yes,
I have all the contacts
or Spanish
mixed so good German good
Mallorina and everything that all
work because that's
the biggest problem in Mallorca that you
have craftsmen on the floor who then
manana manana so typical tomorrow morning
I'll come today I'll come tomorrow so
the typical phenomenon what you  I know
that they don't work that way,
but I've been in Mallorca for 16 years now,
so I now have
a really good network overall with all the
people who also work. There
are even statistics, you told me in the
preliminary interview that your company has
one  of the most economically
profitable companies in
the entire region is gone across all sectors,
so that means you can say it's a great
success for you. At the same time, it's
a brokerage office, which means the entire
economic power of the island is
n't that big that you're in the right place  80
or something like that 82 yes 82 the most
successful
company in Mallorca from an economic point of view, i.e. profit,
I have to say that now that you're
repeating it again and
telling it, it's unbelievable because I
have to say it's not just
brokers but how  you also say it,
all companies are hotel chains,
all companies that exist on Mallorca IB
minora vmentera, hotel chains,
restaurants, everything insurance,
whatever, I'm in 82nd place with my
small mini-business internationally
and have millions in profit, exactly right,
yes, that's what I mean  That speaks for
you of course, but of course it
also speaks a bit against the overall
economic power of the region. No, yes,
they should make an effort or my yes, I
mean if you do it in Hamburg
probably or in I do
n't know in Bavaria or logically there
G's probably difficult
To come to 80th place because there are huge
corporations, medium-sized companies without end, no, that's
right, exactly as you say,
it's definitely so that companies
could make even more sales, but
of course in the end it's a small island
and yes, I think it's great, but  Of course, as you
say, it's actually true, there
could actually be more, there are
a few special
highlights in the last few years,
what an anecdote that you
can't tell now. A highlight, for example, was
that I had a customer from
Düsseldorf  She is Russian and
then said they would like to convert the entire
basement into a ballet hall. I say
who should come to dance there
because her two girls and 12 would
like to become ballet artists and dancers
and that is why
the entire 300 m basement was actually converted into a ballet hall
equipped with this pole that you
then have and with mirrors and so on
and then of course there were
customers who, for example, built their own
helipad and a helicopter landing pad
or I had a customer who
was allowed to build something there, you have to
He applied for a license and
he actually got it
because it was okay given the location of the
property. If it had been in the
Finker location there was
no way he would have gotten the license, but
that worked and then I had
one too  customer who wanted
a golf tee box like a
putting green or something like that, I do
n't play golf so I don't know the ropes, but it has something like a Putin green or something like
that but in my opinion you
also deal with unbelievable celebrities so
now I have John  Yes,
it doesn't really get any bigger than that, yes, and there are
also a lot of athletes where I say man,
awesome, so my my my buddy, for example, is
a huge football fan and when I
say man, I somehow
just had coffee with so and so
S wants me  I'm kidding, but
I have a customer, I'm
not allowed to say his name, but he came to me after
three hours. We had something to eat for three hours
Should I
tell you what it is? I'll say what because he
says you have
n't even asked me anything about football in three hours
and that's never happened in my
life. I'm okay. I do
n't know anything about football either
Do it from left
to right but I'm not the
biggest football fan and he thought that was really
cool and I have a lot of footballers,
a lot of business leaders, athletes
in general and people from the show from
the showbis and so on, really very
exciting interesting personalities,
yes, what can you say  so but it now sounds
as if there are actually more
footballers and and show than really
industry I would have thought W the price they
are more industrial families
on the move no also so it's the mix that
makes it also so we I
many also many customers where everyone
I often find that really crazy when
everyone in the world knows the product
or where they know it can be
bought somehow all over the world
or what I had, for example, he has
car parts from a huge
family who make car parts suppliers
and so on  knows the whole world where
you then think, okay, in every car all over
the world there is a thing built by a
part of them that does
n't even exist and with me they buy the house
for 15 million, so that's
always a phenomenon  for people
to call and who then suddenly sits in my
car with
some well-known
American stars or S that you
can name because they don't listen anyway
but they all listen when I'm
here in the German podcast no no, I
actually don't always like to talk  about it because I
can honestly see exactly Desh on television, maybe I haven't followed the
show that intensively yet,
so I wouldn't
know it or get it, there are some, for example
the mother example was also quite funny,
the mother of I also got to
know the event  Mother
why the mother what does he want with the
mother of nomy Kel yes but the mother
also gave me an interview for
my Liv, for example. Once a year I have
a lifestyle magazine that comes out called Mr
Lifestyle masteros Lifestyle magazine
comes out with 25,000
For example, the mother of Na with Kempel
then got me the interview from her daughter. These are
actions that
I would also say are the most important thing is that
you cannot be copied. This is the
magazine, the ski that we
are in, on the one hand  from the top hotspots and
coffee cafeterias and restur at
golf clubs in Mallorca for free and
is of course then sent to customers.
Yes, you probably know Mallorca from the
back of your hand, no, yes, and if you
move somewhere there yourself, you want to
move to Wier, that's nice  I mean, it's
always a matter of taste, but I
think it's nice that,
on the one hand, every property has a
minimum size of 2000 madrm, which means you do
n't have the neighbor right next to you
and if you have schnitzel with it,
then you can have potato salad
bring it over but if
privacy is really the order of the day then
it's 10 minutes from Palmer center
you'll be at the airport in 15 minutes you'll
have peace and quiet you
'll have no corners that are particularly
developing right now or where
listeners might say Mens
next time  I'll have to go and have a look at it.
Good, so very nice to visit in
any case and I do
n't think it's bad at all to buy in Balde Mossa.
The whole region of Walde Mossa is a very beautiful region. Then I still find the whole southwest the whole
southwest  So the whole region between
Palmer and Portandras is a great
area in the Alaro Santa Maria
interior of Mallorca, so to speak, how
many people live in Mallorca, a
million about 1 million, so that
means the size of the area, let's
say not the whole of Hamburg, like Munich, no
so yes it was exactly yes
Munich 1,2 or so yes exactly yes that's
the nice thing you don't notice when you
live on Mallorca now and I live
there all year round even in winter you
just don't notice that it's an island
you can see clearly  you always have some kind of
water and sea and so on, but
still it's not like you think
wow, the dog is buried and there's
no one here in the winter and I have the
feeling that this is developing internationally
more so the lie
and so on Michell Obama, for example, is currently
in Munich and gave a speech and he
flew in from Mallorca and
I mean
our Amazon founder and so on
Jeff Bessos and so on whatever their
names are all with us this year  They
sailed around on their yachts in Mallorca and
then, for example, Jeff Wessos had
his huge
luxury yacht in the harbor in Palma all summer.
Well, there are really calibers there
now, it's running right there, it
's eating there. Michel Obama, for example, was in the
marina in Portals  eat then
we have Katherine C Jones and Michael
Douglas, for example, they have had
a Finke in Mallorca for years, so it
really attracts the right
people now, you can clearly say yes,
I am, I am ready for everyone, I am in the
middle of it, I have them  top houses
they can all come to me exactly so
they can also rent as I said rent
everything rent buy live vitalfinker that's how
I saw that is also an
object D you rent a Remus
vitalfinker I had the idea and
I was lying there on the beach with myself
Last year my health wasn't going so
well because I was just working too much
and then I thought, okay,
actually you should combine the whole topic of
health, relaxation, recreation with real estate,
so again it was a
crazy idea, so I was completely crazy when
I was in the tha hotel  Miami on the beach
Miami Beach and thought about what can
I do with it now I'm resting
but still want to
push my business forward what kind of combination is that
so I
thought to myself I'm looking for a house
Buy a house in zombeder of course
again  back in cedar and make it
a Remus like talfinker means
you can rent it as a customer and go on
holiday there but irend so relaxing
holiday means we have a
sauna for example we
have a padel tennis court which is
completely popular now in
Spain anyway and it's coming  Also now
to Germany this petle tennis
then I have an outdoor gym a
bit like calestenics park a
bit like Ninja Warrior then I have
a yogap platform and then we have
herb garden and vegetable garden h had everything
grown I had everything grown
I renovated the house  I leave everything
very harmoniously in such neutral colors
with natural stannous floors and everything in a
cream color and that works extremely well, especially
with athletes or
now I've just rented it out to
the startuper who also says I want
my best as a bit of an
incentive  We
bring in entrepreneurs who then go on vacation there
and we develop
different ideas of cool things and so on
and they all come via social
media and know everyone completely about
social media write DM on Instagram exactly exactly exactly yes
right ask when
is it free and  We want to rent with so and so
many people, can we
come there, how much does it cost and so on, yes,
but I hear a little bit about it, you
're also a big Miami fan in your private life, oh I
love America, yes, I'm totally
crazy when it comes to marketing  So
I just love this way,
this positive and yes, this
way of marketing, it's
totally American, as I
actually do it myself in Europe or
on Mallorca on my little maorker,
yes and Dubai is not an issue for you, no,
I don't think so  Dubai really sucks, I think
it's really bad because I'm
giving it another
chance. I'm staying
at the Mandarine Oriental Hotel in
Dubai for a week in November and if it doesn't perform for the
whole week then I'll
never be there again  go there and just get to
know each other or I've been
to Dubai quite a few times and I've
never really liked it, I was even
there before New Year's Eve last year. I can
also tell you exactly why the problem
is that in my opinion there are a
lot of strange pseudo ones  Entrepreneurs are
where you don't actually want to know
behind the scenes how they earned their money.
Then
I'm a
bit skeptical about the whole Bitcoin topic, I have
no idea about it either, but I don't find it
super serious either  and
then there are all these strange
influencer ladies scantily clad and stuff like
that I don't know I don't know I ca
n't say a lot of people are raving about it, especially
in the industry, I always hear
that it's somehow never
there but it should be good on the West  It's
no longer a question of fish for a moment, they say
here, why are they all pulling? I
mean, I pay my taxes diligently and I
'm still in 82nd place with the
most successful companies and I pay
my taxes in Spain very cleanly and
quite properly and now we should
n't people  Now they're
suddenly all migrating to you, they're all going
there, we shouldn't say
that it's so beautiful there and that they're
going there because it's 50° there in the summer,
the beach can say whatever you
want, the beaches in Dubai are
[ __ ]  They're terribly ugly and
you're sitting there with the crane in the water because
they're building islands there,
so the people who
say Dubai is the best, of course
Dubai is cool if you go there for a week
and then go party there and
have the coolest restaurants there  and what
I schiki miiki Dior and bagatel and
what I namos and what it's all called,
all the intrefs but if you
ask me it's all kind of a
pseudo thing where some
entrepreneurs go there who just
want to save their taxes, so that's
actually why it's like that  The whole climate wall and
these sustainability issues, things that
affect you and that also
affect Mallorcans, a huge issue, the whole issue of
sustainability, i.e. sustainability
in principle, that was also the
idea of ​​saying you can make a
vitalfinker to grow your own vegetables and
all that stuff  a
little bit about sustainability,
also photovoltaics and so on with
energy supply and the whole topic m but
also with my customers and that's
a bit of a double-edged
sword or knife, let's say, because
they obviously fly in in the private chat
and then talk about it  but of course
how important sustainability is, that's
a huge topic and it
always causes a huge discussion but
I still think it's good that even
such blatant entrepreneurs still
think about it, e.g. I now have one
who said I'm buying  only a house
that has geothermal energy, so that means core
earth drilling s then that you
supply your house with geothermal energy and that there are
now two
property developers in Mallorca who also
do that and then nine or ten
depending on the size of the house  then just drill a hole
and I still think that's
good that people no matter
how many billions and millions they
have then also say that's important to them
and is in their hearts, that
energy can be saved wherever possible
mm so a big topic  Definitely
I think climate glue sucks
I have to say that to be honest, so this
theater I was in Berlin again
a few weeks ago when I see
them sticking themselves on the street,
I now think it's totally
crazy and what I have on ibiz  I
saw there were also customers who had their
yacht in IBZ lying in the harbor next to this
yacht. I don't remember that,
I think it was the woman who was the reason or
the heiress of Walmart who then
had her yacht lying there in Ibizza and they
then completely became that  was
sprayed all over with paint, so
I mean that's what's the point?
So what's the point of
spraying some private jets at the airport with paint or a
huge luxury yacht for 200 million, that's
not going to help you, so
that's nonsense
Attention, yes, but in the wrong direction. To be honest,
I
personally think it's a matter of opinion again.
Yes, you would have had a chance
to get really far
to the Olympics as a rider. Yes, I would have.
The Olympics are always dependent, so you are
very dependent, like in Formula 1
You really depend on the team and
also on the vehicle, in
my case then on the horse. You have to
be really lucky. Maybe
not at the Olympics, but because I'm already in the
national squad anyway and what I
would have been German runner-up at the time  I
can definitely go a long way, but to be honest, I did
n't want to do anything all my life
and do you ride every now and then?
us pull-up
challenge doing it on the agent from
Mallorca will flatten you
[laughter]
that we will pass it in that sense
thank you very much a wahc then
thank you a nine age that looks
clean can't
be me 13
[ __ ]
14 m now Mallorcak that's there  not at all
that's
embarrassing embarrassing me meen basement
we have to do more now one more round
I
15 ne
yes
dre
yes [ __ ] ke where are you like a
victim
how many six
come how many eight
a man man
man success and success sinander
dre oh he wobbles
F yes wel yes a but
thank you very much everything is fine, I'll
be back soon